Oh a new Wonder Woman trainer came out
yesterday bzz yesterday the day before
was Saturday Sun [ __ ] I was going to do
a video on it and then I fell into a
vortex not the usual porn vortex come on
I was Legend of Zelda Brothers well it's
pretty good this is where I knew it
Monday came around and like era people
still want me to talk about the Wonder
Woman trailer say hey let's talk about
it the Wonder Woman trailer starts out
and right away we're like oh we have an
underdog story it's our little Diana
looks at this was sword and she's like
hey who wields the sword her mom's like
that only the coolest of the cool so
sorry not UK you know like sword in
stone like that times the billion but
one day she whale and first thing I
notice is everyone all the amazonian
everyone sounds like gal gadot you could
just tell patty Jenkins the director was
like well everyone's going to just
concentrate on the accent so if they all
have accents totally make sense it does
make sense there's some tough parental
love she's going through right there
beating her ass like Bam Bam Bam she's
blocking blocking blocking she's look
she does a dr. Manhattan like I said
lately I love and we see Chris Pine
still the comic relief you know when she
gets to London he's like this is London
she's like a hideous he's all yeah it's
not for everybody which going from that
to that yeah it sure London looks pretty
dank I will give her that there is a
total callback to the Richard Donner
Superman in his movie knowing someone
shoots at Chris Pine to the pen
totally super man we have ourselves an
action montage and Wonder Woman still
looks good the trailer doesn't really
show as much more than what we already
knew it's coming up from the other two
Wonder Woman trailers it may elaborate
on what we already knew but generally
speaking we knew the gist my question is
how prominent is Ares going to be in
this movie
well generally speaking the gods for
that matter this takes place during a
World War Ares I assume either gets
power from that or is causing it or both
and she needs to take him down but Ares
is one of many gods like how often are
there going to be in the movie it's just
going to be like you kind of hear about
Ares and then you seem at the end are
you going to see him throughout
antagonizing her is going to be like
Clash of the Titans where we go up there
on Mount Olympus we just kind of see
them hanging out in their togas eating
great [ __ ] with people that gooey
let's brick Chris Pines legs get on out
one is Wonder Woman does genuinely look
great the trailers for the DC Cinematic
Universe movies have always looked good
and I've enjoyed some more than others
some people are on the same boat they've
enjoyed some more than others some
enjoyed the ones
didn't like more than I did and the ones
I like they like less or even hated some
people love them all some people hate
them all I'm hoping Wonder Woman puts
everyone on the level like at worst
people walked out like yeah well is
pretty good is entertaining and that
best people can walk out like holy [ __ ]
dude DC Cinematic Universe should truck
on because of this so I'm interested I'm
excited Wonder Woman because I want to
hear what you guys think about the new
Wonder Woman trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it we're a
prominent do you think Aries and the
other gods are going to be in this movie
I notice but let's speculate speculating
among trailers it's what makes it fun so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]